ce 30 juillet 2022 on a appris la mort
de l'actrice michelle nichols notamment
connu pour le rôle du lieutenant ouvra
dans la série originale star trek de
1966 à 1969 pourquoi c'est important
tout simplement parce que c'était la
première fois qu'on voyait une femme
noire d'être un rôle aussi important en
gros qui était pas là pour jouer une
femme de ménage ou une nounou c'est
quand même la quatrième personne la plus
gradée
[Rires]
mais saviez vous qu'elle a failli
abandonner la série pour se consacrer à
sa carrière de chanteuse dès la fin de
la première saison mais elle a été
convaincue de rester par un de ses fans
et pas n'importe quel fan parce qu'il
s'agissait de martin luther king
lui-même d'après lui son rôle dans
certains qui étaient bien trop important
parce qu'il permettait à tous les gens
de couleurs de s'identifier à une femme
forte et en responsabilité et il a eu
raison puisque le lieutenant ogura
serait une grosse source d'inspiration
pour l'astronaute mike jamison qui
deviendra en 1992 la première femme
noire à aller dans l'espace d'ailleurs
elle fera elle-même un caméo dans la
série star trek next generation en
jouant le rôle du lieutenant palmer dans
l'épisode deuxième chance mais c'est pas
fini